[applaudissements]
ville minière
pour cela je travaille dans la mine depuis plus de trois ans
nous sommes à moi, le travail est dur et dangereux, eh bien, je
Je me suis blessé dans la mine. Eh bien, d'une manière ou d'une autre
Je me suis blessé, j'y suis resté quatre
mois Voici encore du travail Non pour
je vais travailler dans ma propre entreprise
extrait le charbon par méthode souterraine environ 10
ans notre production annuelle de charbon
représente environ 15 000 tonnes par an
notre entreprise travaille actuellement
120 mineurs Nous vendons du charbon à l'intérieur
Le Kirghizistan et
Kazakhstan
notre principal charbon
[applaudissements]